welcome back to 8701
in the previous lecture we have seen how
the gauge botons
the w and the z boson acquire mass while
the photon
remains marvelous through the hicks
mechanism
we introduced a new field a new complex
duplet
scalar field the higgs field
which then broke through its vacuum
expectation value
the symmetry and then through the
coupling to the gauge bosons
they acquired mass great um
but we also have to find a solution for
the fermions we cannot simply add a
fermion
mass term to the left margin that would
change or that could violate
break the gauge invariant so how do we
do this
we do this in a very similar way uh even
easier
but before we look into how this is done
let's have a look at the masses itself
it's spectacular
the top quark is our heaviest known
fermion
has a mass of about 172
gb the tau has a mass of
1.77 gv the muon
is an order of magnitude lighter with
0.1 guv
and for the electron
for the electron we have to go to 0.51
mev okay and we haven't even tried to
understand
or we're not able to measure actually
the masses of neutrinos we were talking
about neutrinos in one of the following
lectures
so here you have six orders of magnitude
and you have to go
further down here um in order to find
the neutrinos on this mass scale so we
have to have a mass
giving mechanism which allows you know
this
broad spectrum of masses to occur
and the very simple attack mechanism
which was introduced to the standard
model
is one where the particle simply
interacts with the higgs field
so we have our higgs field here we have
a let's say we have a left-handed
particle coming in
and the the um
the interaction with the higgs field
turns it into a right-handed particle
this is a little bit simplified but what
we do there here is
simply introducing terms into the
lacrossing which do nothing else
we turn our left-handed particles via
the interaction with the higgs field
into right-handed
and the other way around and we have to
do this for up type particles
and for downtime particles so here's
another view of this the strength here
is the mass of the particle over
the vacuum expectation value
this number here this this number this
lambda d
is the so-called yokaba coupling um and
those two cover couplings now change
from fermion to fermion each fermion
comes with their own you cover coupling
it's basically a free parameter in our
theory in the standard model
so instead of talking about the masses
being three parameters we talk about the
coupling to the higgs field as the
parameter
but they are one of one and the same
all right so this was rather
straightforward it's a simple coupling
you introduce this term our talk
and then hope for the best that it's
actually realized in nature and we'll
see
that this is indeed the case for some of
the fermions later